We talked about these different methods,
something you know,
something you have,
those are called factors.
The first one is sort of
the secret you know factor.
The second is something you have factor.
The third is who you are factor.
So it doesn't have to
be just one factor.
You can actually have
a multi-factor authentication.
One of the quiz questions,
the smart phone and PIN for
example, the password and
the PIN that is sent or
the code that is sent to you,
the password is something you know.
The PIN that is sent to you on the smart
phone is based on the smart phone which
is something you have, for example.
So you can use more than one factor to
actually make authentication stronger.
So, as we said we use more than
one method, you type password but
also send code via SMS, and
this code goes to your phone,
actually Gmail when you
create an account uses this.
These are called phone verified
accounts or PVAs, mainly
to provide protection against bots
that create a lot of these accounts.
So this is multi-factor,
because it's not just a password, but
also this code that comes
to a device that you have.
So that's the second factor.
Your ATM card and
PIN that you use to get money out of
an ATM machine is actually a two factor.
The PIN is something you know,
the card itself is something you have.
So these are two factors.
There's another example of
a multi-factor authentication.
The other methods that use
things like where you are,
your location and IP address of
the machine, OS fingerprint,
these sort of add a little bit of
more to the authentication process.
So when you have multi factor
authentication of course that attacker
must defeat both to successfully
compromise the authentication method
we have in place.
So the authentication we talked
about sort of going to the system,
having a trusted path to the system,
providing the password, fortunately,
a lot of times you do authentication
over the network where the system
may be thousands of miles away from you.
In fact, a lot of remote services
we access whether it's our email or
our banking system and so on are of
course, we don't walk up to them.
So, what happens in this case?
We don't have a trusted
path to the system,
remember we sent physical wires from
your keyboard to your machine right in
front of you in close proximity,
That's how we get that trusted path.
The network is open and, obviously,
the same thing doesn't hold there.
So we don't have a trusted path,
especially when we access
in remote services.
So network authentication
introduces a new problem.
But how do you deal with the absence
of this trusted part that we've been
talking about?
Well, actually, we need crypto to
secure the network communication.
So when you talk about network
security in a different lesson,
we're going to address this.
Of course you have to worry
about different kind of threats,
such as man-in-the-middle and
things like that.
But the reason I want to mention,
although we're going to
cover this in network security topic,
is that authentication
relies on this fundamental
requirement of this trusted path.
In a network,
you're not going to have that.
So you'll have to do something else
about the lack of the trusted path, or
some method you have to find to
secure the network over which you're
going to send the evidence for
authenticating yourself.